people really want to challenge me about
all these women coming forward someone
came up to me was like well how do these
women even remember what happened like
oh because we're known for our amazing
ability to forget shit ah
we're known for just letting things go
after a while it's our thing
maybe some people don't understand that
when you get harassed at a young age you
might not even put together that that's
what's occurring until later in life
when you're an adult that was one of my
experiences when i was 19 years old i
got a job as an extra in a television
show and the first day i was there the
director who was at least 65 years old
invited me into his trailer for lunch so
i go into his trailer and i know what
you're thinking why did you go into his
trailer
because i was an idiot
i was 19 years old no one had told me
trailers were bad there was a lot of
shit i didn't know i also thought clear
bra straps were clear
i also thought that lady living with my
aunt was her roommates i
also thought guys could be allergic to
latex there was a lot of shit
i hadn't figured out yet
don't blame me
so of course i go into his trailer out
of nowhere he just lunges at me i didn't
understand what's happening because he
was so much older than me i thought he
fell i was like are you okay oh my god
are you passing away what's happening
no idea what to do with that story i
don't remember the guy's name but the
good news is i did accidentally stumble
upon a great way to deal with harassment
at work from a creepy guy just pretend
you think he's having a medical
emergency
next time a guy's like hey sweetie you
want to get a drink later just go oh my
gosh
gary thinks he's in my
don't know if it's like league
or maybe it's a show gary thinks that i
would fuck him we've gotta call it
ambulance it's bad
don't get angry just get very
compassionate
that's my new approach
i don't even get angry at cat callers
anymore my new thing with cat callers is
just do what they ask
because then they'll realize it's not at
all what they want
next time a guy's like hey baby smile
just be like